Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
Wahou !
Vous êtes nombreux,
vous êtes attentifs,
et en plus, ils ont été bons.
À part ça, je n'ai pas la pression.
Je vais vous parler de certaines
expériences que j'ai pu vivre ou voir.
Ici, vous voyez
ce que je fais aujourd'hui.
J'ai eu l'occasion de faire
d'autres métiers auparavant.
Dans ce cadre-là,
j'ai eu quelques expériences.
Je me rappelle notamment ce coup de fil
que j'ai reçu un dimanche, fin juillet.
C'était Pierre.
Pierre me dit au téléphone :
« Écoute David, j'ai besoin de toi.
Il faut absolument que tu dépublies
un article sur un de nos sites web. »
Je dis : « Pierre,
On est dimanche,
ça ne peut pas attendre demain ? »
« Écoute David, ce n'est pas possible.
Un journaliste a fait une erreur
et sur un article qui doit parler
des bouchons des départs en vacances,
il a mis en ligne une vidéo
et cette vidéo,
il s'agit de terroristes
qui martyrisent des otages. »
Je dis : « Wahou, oui, c'est embêtant.
Mais,
tu ne peux pas t'en occuper ?
- David, je suis sur la route,
avec les enfants, la bagnole est pleine,
impossible de me connecter.
Il faut que tu fasses quelque chose.
- Je veux bien mais ce journaliste,
s'il vient de faire l'erreur,
il ne peut pas s'en occuper ?
- David, je vais te dire un truc.
C'est le gardien qui m'appelé.
Le journaliste, en s'apercevant de
son erreur, est tombé dans les pommes. »
Dimanche 7 mai 2017,
J'arrive dans les bureaux de l'équipe
numérique de France TV Info.
Moi, je dois surveiller ce qu'il se passe
sur les réseaux sociaux,
suite à un logiciel développé
par mon équipe.
Depuis le matin,
les équipes techniques arrivent.
Tout le monde répète.
Tout se passe bien.
Les premiers résultats
de sondage arrivent.
Là, il y a un petit problème
de format dans les fichiers.
Je sens l'équipe de gauche
qui commence à travailler
et qui crie au bout d'un moment :
« OK, c'est bon, c'est ajusté. »
19 heures 55.
Résultat dans cinq minutes.
19 heures 58.
Résultat dans deux minutes.
push résultat.
Ça s'est bien passé, vous aviez cru que...
Un autre exemple, un peu plus récent.
Je reçois un coup de fil au bureau.
Un informaticien me précise
qu'un de ses collaborateurs
n'a plus accès à ses fichiers.
Je lui demande ce qu'il se passe.
Il me dit ne pas comprendre :
« Tous les noms de fichiers ont changé.
Maintenant, ils s'appellent tous .lock.
point, L, O, C, K. »
Aïe !
Inquiétude dans l'équipe.
Pourquoi ?
C'est sûrement un cryptolocker
qui a chiffré les fichiers.
La phase suivante, c'est quoi ?
C'est un pirate qui va demander une rançon
pour rendre les fichiers ré-utilisables.
Au sein de l'équipe,
la pression commence à monter.
Moi, je commence à avoir chaud.
Comme maintenant.
J'ai les mains froides.
Et là, chacun y va de sa suggestion.
Il y en a un qui dit :
« David, je vais regarder dans les mails
pour voir quel type de messages
cette personne a reçus. »
Un autre dit :
« Wahou ! Va falloir prévenir la DG
parce que ça peut être chaud, là. »
Un troisième dit,
un peu dépité :
« Pfff, encore un imbécile qui a cliqué
sur n'importe quoi, il y en a marre ! »
Là, je me dis :
« C'est inquiétant,
on risque de se disperser. »
C'est ma première expérience
dans ce genre de cas.
Je prends une grande respiration
et je me dis :
« David, que faut-il faire ?
Il y a plusieurs idées,
il faut s'organiser. »
Je me mets au paperboard
et je liste les actions à réaliser.
On se les répartit
et c'est parti !
Là aussi, je vous rassure,
tout s'est bien terminé.
Je viens de vous lister
quelques situations.
Dans un premier cas,
une situation inattendue
qui mène à la perte de contrôle :
le journaliste est tombé dans les pommes.
Dans le deuxième cas,
un imprévu,
mais une situation répétée
depuis des mois,
des choses maîtrisées
qui finalement permettent
de gérer l'imprévu
et l'objectif est atteint sans encombres.
Dans le dernier cas,
celui dans lequel j'étais
davantage impliqué,
là, à un moment, il faut se dire :
« Bon, on se reconcentre.
Il faut définir ce qu'il y a à faire ;
on revient aux primordiaux. »
Tout ça pour vous expliquer
que les types de réactions
peuvent être différents.
Dans les réactions avec
une connotation plutôt négative,
on peut avoir l'effet syncope,
la sidération.
On a déjà vu et entendu quelques exemples.
On peut avoir des gens
qui au contraire vont fuir la situation.
Ils vont s'en aller, disparaître.
Dans des situations de pression,
certains auront une agitation motrice.
Je ne sais pas si vous avez pu
observer les intervenants.
Certains marchent de cette façon-là,
tout le temps de leur présentation.
D'autres sont revenus à
leurs fondamentaux, le chef d'orchestre
qui s'est plutôt balancé comme ça,
un peu pour trouver ses habitudes
et se rassurer avec la mesure.
D'autres encore ont
une conduite automatique réflexe.
Un exemple que j'ai vécu
sur un incident de sécurité,
où effectivement on avait besoin
que tout le monde soit mobilisé.
Mais en fait, une des personnes
a continué à lire automatiquement
ses mails pour s'échapper,
revenir à des automatismes
dans le cadre de cette situation.
Vous pouvez avoir des réactions
plus positives.
Certains les ont évoquées.
Finalement, la pression, c'est top,
ça donne de l'énergie.
Ça permet d'avancer.
Ça donne envie.
Vous pouvez avoir
dans le cadre de réactions positives
ce qu'on va appeler
la répétition de protocoles.
On s'est préparés
et on sait qu'on a la pression.
Mais on sait qu'on doit
respecter le protocole.
Ça devient un automatisme positif
car on fait ce qu'il faut.
Je pense que c'est le cas
dans le milieu médical.
Dans le milieu de la cybersécurité aussi.
Ce sont des choses qu'on essaie de faire.
On fait de la gestion de crise
et on essaie de répéter et de s'entraîner.
En fait, ce qu'il faut retenir -
ça a déjà été évoqué -
c'est que chacun vit la pression
suivant sa personnalité,
suivant la situation,
suivant l'impact et l'enjeu
pour lui-même et son environnement.
Pas besoin d'être médecin
pour vivre la pression.
Pas besoin de sauter en parachute
Tout le monde peut se trouver
dans une situation de pression.
Vous aussi, vous vous êtes trouvés
dans des situations de pression.
Vous avez passé des examens,
des concours.
Vous avez participé
à des campagnes de liste.
N’est-ce pas ?
Il n’y a pas longtemps, c’est très récent.
Dans le cas de situations
que j’ai pu vivre moi aussi,
je me rappelle une démonstration
que je devais faire sur un salon.
C’était le salon de l’Éducation nationale.
Et on présentait une offre de vidéos
éducatives à la demande sur Internet.
La pression était là
car c’était l’aboutissement du travail
de toute une équipe depuis plus d’un an.
C’était la première présentation
sur un stand avec des invités.
Et le Ministre de l’Éducation nationale
en personne y assistait.
Donc oui, là aussi, j’avais la [pression].
Comme je l’ai dit tout à l’heure,
j’avais chaud, les mains froides,
comme d’hab.
Et là, je me suis demandé
ce que j’allais faire.
J’ai pris une bonne respiration
et je me suis raccroché
à ce que j’avais préparé,
à mon texte que j’avais en tête,
aux papiers que j’avais sous la main,
comme aujourd’hui, vous l’avez vu.
Dans le cas de situations de pression,
finalement, il y a des pressions qu’on
peut s’inventer et qui disparaissent.
Par exemple, je joue au tennis.
Je me suis inscrit
à un certain nombre de compétitions
et je fais un peu de compétition
par équipes.
Rassurez-vous, vous ne me verrez
jamais à Roland Garros.
Je me souviens l’année dernière,
d’un match que je devais jouer
contre quelqu’un bien plus fort que moi.
Mais je ne me suis pas
du tout mis la pression.
Je savais que de toute façon,
c’était perdu d’avance.
J’y suis allé.
Dès le début,
je me suis dit : « David, tu ne risques
rien car de toute façon, tu vas perdre.
Bon, vas-y, joue ! »
Non, je n’ai pas gagné, je n’ai pas gagné.
(Rires)
Désolé.
Mais par contre,
je n’étais pas mécontent de moi
et j’avais fait un bon match.
Autre situation : au début de ma carrière.
J'ai commencé en régie finale
au sein d'une télévision
qui venait de se monter.
La chaîne était toute nouvelle.
J'étais en régie finale et nous étions
trois équipes de trois personnes
pour assurer la diffusion de 5 heures 30
du matin à minuit le soir.
Nous étions trois équipes
de trois personnes
mais nous savions manifestement
qu'au bout de trois mois,
nous ne serions plus
que trois équipes de deux personnes.
Concrètement, on avait tous la pression.
Là aussi, j'avais la pression ;
comment j'ai fait ?
Je me suis dit : « David, il faut y aller.
C'est la chance d'avoir ton job
à la télé, ce dont tu rêvais.
Dans ce cadre-là, tu bosses ! »
Donc, j'ai potassé
les docs et les procédures,
pour être prêt et savoir gérer
à tout moment.
Quelques conseils concrets
sur comment gérer la pression.
Je vais raisonner temporellement :
avant, pendant, après.
Avant : il est important
que vous vous connaissiez,
que vous identifiiez vos propres signes
de réaction à la pression,
que vous identifiiez
quand vous passez sous pression,
quand vous atteignez la limite qui fait
que vous risquez de vous sentir mal.
Avant, il est aussi important
de se préparer.
On va parler de répétitions.
Vous avez répété
votre présentation, là, tous ?
Oui !
Ça permet de se sentir plus à l'aise,
normalement.
Cette préparation est importante.
Je sais que j'ai plutôt l'habitude
d'anticiper, de me projeter,
de me demander ce qu'il va se passer
et comment je vais le vivre, d'imaginer.
J'étais très content d'avoir vu
une photo de l'amphi
quand j'ai pu préparer cette intervention.
À un moment, je sais que,
quand j'étais au numérique,
j'aimais beaucoup prévoir la catastrophe.
Donc, je demandais constamment
à mes équipes
de préparer quelque chose, un plan B.
Au début, cela les agaçait,
après, ils ont rigolé,
puis mon surnom à un moment
donné fut Monsieur Plan B.
Pendant : c'est important de pouvoir
observer, voir ce qu'il se passe.
Voir comment vous, vous réagissez.
Si vous commencez à ne pas être bien,
si votre esprit commence à s'embrouiller,
dans le cas d'une situation de pression,
il est important de prendre du recul.
Vous pouvez le faire
de différentes façons.
Vous pouvez vous poser,
(Inspire)
prendre une grande respiration,
c'est important d'oxygéner l'esprit
et d'oxygéner le corps.
Vous pouvez bouger, sortir.
Vous pouvez aussi observer
ce qu'il se passe chez les autres.
Vous pouvez avoir l'attitude de
la personne sous pression qui tape du pied
ou celle de la personne qui va se mettre
à taper des doigts sur la table.
Je suis sûr qu'il y en a beaucoup
d'entre vous
qui ont l'habitude
de jouer avec leur stylo,
de le faire tourner
autour de leurs doigts.
C'est peut-être un signe chez vous
de pression, de sensibilité à la pression.
Il faut réagir aussi
face à cette situation-là,
pour éventuellement sortir quelqu'un
de la réunion,
si c'est une réunion de crise,
par exemple.
Le risque, c'est finalement d'avoir
des gens qui vont nuire à la réaction
s'ils ne sont pas à même
de faire face à la pression.
C'est pour ça.
Identifiez les signes,
identifiez ce qu'il se passe,
éventuellement, aidez la personne
à prendre du recul.
Ça peut être très simple.
Vous identifiez cette personne-là
qui n'est plus en mesure de réagir
et d'être dans l'action.
Vous la sortez du groupe
et vous l'emmenez.
Vous essayez de la faire parler,
de comprendre ce qu'il se passe.
C'est un moyen pour elle d'extérioriser.
Vous pouvez vérifier si elle est capable
de traiter les choses qu'elle a à faire.
Et si ce n'est pas le cas,
posez-vous la question :
« N'est-ce pas mieux que je sorte
cette personne du groupe
car elle risque de nuire ? »
Dans des situations
que vous rencontrez aussi,
vous allez avoir des rendez-vous
avec vos managers.
Vous deviendrez manager vous-même.
Il est intéressant dans le cadre
des entretiens que vous pourrez avoir
avec vos collaborateurs,
d'identifier à quel moment
ils commencent à être sous pression.
Et là, c'est important
de les faire parler,
leur faire dire : « Écoute,
il y a quelque chose qui ne va pas.
Il y a quelque chose
que tu n'arrives pas à gérer ?
Tu as besoin d'aide ? »
Après, il est aussi intéressant
de décompresser.
Après la situation de pression,
(Souffle), on respire,
on peut se dire : « Ça y est,
c'est bon, c'est passé. »
Mais c'est intéressant d'aller au-delà.
Dans le cadre de réactions,
il y a des choses qu'on fait bien,
des choses qu'on fait mal,
des choses qu'on peut mieux faire.
C'est super intéressant
et important de débriefer,
c'est-à-dire d'examiner ensemble
comment on peut mieux faire
la prochaine fois.
C'est ainsi qu'on progresse
et qu'on saura mieux gérer
et qu'on peut être amené
à mieux faire face à la pression.
Après, il y a autre chose d'important,
si ça s'est bien passé
et si tout le monde est d'accord,
c'est fêter.
Mais ça, je sais que faire la fête,
vous savez faire ça aussi.
Enfin, il me reste quelques minutes,
je voudrais profiter de ce moment
pour faire une petite expérience.
Je vais appeler à me rejoindre
un Première année.
Je vais appeler,
un garçon.
Un garçon,
dont le prénom commence par la lettre D.
Non, non, rassurez-vous,
je ne vais faire venir personne.
Mais ce qui m'intéresse là,
c'est que vous vous demandiez
comment chacun de vous a réagi.
J'ai vu des rires, des têtes se tourner.
Je suis sûr que certains
se sont enfoncés dans leur fauteuil
et qui ont regardé leurs pieds.
Il y en a d'autres, qui intérieurement,
au contraire, se sont redressés
et se sont dit :
« Ouais, moi, moi, je veux y aller. »
Il y en a même un qui s'est levé,
vous n'avez qu'à voir...
Donc, voilà.
Tout ça pour vous permettre
de vous poser des questions
et de vous demander
comment vous réagissez à la pression
et d'identifier les premiers signes.
Enfin, pour terminer, une petite phrase
qui peut servir de conseil.
Je vous invite à lire cette phrase,
je vous en parle après.
[Sur le plus haut trône du monde,
on n'est jamais assis que sur son cul
- Michel de Montaigne, 1588]
Surprenant !
Ce qui est important, c'est que,
quand vous serez dans un entretien
et que l'enjeu est énorme pour vous,
quand vous êtes face à quelqu'un
qui vous impressionne de folie,
eh bien, repensez à cette phrase,
elle devrait vous aider à vous apaiser
et à assurer votre entretien
ou votre présentation.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)